autre titre de cette édition en france
trente mille foyers modestes ne
bénéficieront plus de la trêve hivernale
dès mardi et pourront être expulsés par
les propriétaires même si la ministre du
logement souhaite que ces expulsions
soient adaptées au cas par cas
la trêve hivernale a été prolongée de
deux mois en raison de la crise
sanitaire manifestation s'est déroulée
cet après-midi à paris pour dénoncer les
expulsions elle a eu lieu à l'appel
d'une quarantaine d'associations dont le
droit au logement notre reporter lucas
léger a suivi cette manifestation les
manifestants ont défilé entre le
cimetière du père lachaise et la place
de la république où une partie des
centaines des migrants qui les
accompagnaient ont peut être pris en
charge dans des bus les autres ont
attendu ici sur la place de la
république qu'une solution soit trouvée
pour eux les manifestants à l'appel du
dal se sont rassemblés pour demander au
gouvernement de renoncer à la fin de la
trêve hivernale les expulsions doivent
recommencer
en juin ils veulent que l'état trouve
des solutions pérennes notamment la
construction de hlm je vous propose
d'écouter jean baptiste eyraud du dal
que j'ai pu interroger au début de cette
manifestation
madame baron a autorisé les expressions
elle le dit nous on dit pas qu'il faut
expulser on dit qu'il faut suspendre les
expulsions et éventuellement relogés
préalablement à l'expulsion les
personnes pour lesquelles il ya vraiment
nécessité pour les raisons qu'on a
évoqué ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point à 10 par relogement des
personnes elle dit relogement ou un
hébergement
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'elle va héberger
parce qu'on sait très bien aujourd'hui
il n'y a plus suffisamment de logements
sociaux plus suffisamment d'attribution
on est en situation de baisse on va dire
des des attributions possible
heureusement sociale et de
d'effondrement de la production de
logements sociaux
avec ces manifestants plusieurs
personnes inquiètes pour leur futur je
vous propose d'écouter quelques
témoignages que j'ai pu recueillir au
début aussi de cette manifestation
j'ai eu peur d'être à la rue j'ai peur
de plus avoir de travail de plus et là
je suis dans une situation où ça va
remonter
ça y est décédé confirme ce serait un
moyen de 2 des purées la dette de me
remettre à zéro est remonté et n'est ce
pas il n'est ce pas là la seule n'est ce
pas là il n'est ce pas la place quoi ce
que vous voyez aujourd'hui c'est ça
concerne souci gens là y compris ceux
qui depuis très très longtemps n'ont pas
trouvé de logement
c'est déplorable de voir des gens comme
mon cas parmi d'autres que je suis
toujours dans la rue soit à l'auberge
soit les amis de gauche à droite et que
parent à yviers ou par autre enfin
frapper des 10 des fins des portes
il n'y a pas d'entente la ministre
manuel wargon veut qu'il n'y ait
personne à la rue à l'issue des
expulsions et que les préfets se
focalise sur les cas qui posent le plus
de problèmes notamment pour les
bailleurs qui ont besoin de l'argent des
loyers pour vivre des indemnités sont
aussi prévues mais toutes ses promesses
et bien ici elle ne convainquent pas et
les manifestants sont inquiets pour les
trente mille foyers qui sont concernés
par cette fin de trêve hivernale